it's setting up
action
[Music]
good afternoon happy sabbath and welcome
everyone to the official third episode
of the feel the pillar series special
edition
today we are joined with special guests
elder
randy skeet brother jonathan david
archie
brother kevin gomez sister alana kwashi
sisters and sister sasha shay weeks as
we discuss
the second coming today we'll be
answering questions like what is the
nature
of christ's second coming is it a secret
rapture
what will happen in the millennium my
name is denisha mccurchion and i'm so
happy that you have joined us today
let's begin with the word of prayer
dear heavenly father we thank you for
your
grace toward us you have kept us
thus far by faith and the great hope of
the christian is the second coming so
even as we have this discussion
please lead and guide us into your truth
be with your man's servant elder feet
and speak your words of
life through him we thank you for being
with us
and for directing this session in the
name of jesus christ we pray
amen
today we are blessed to have brother
kevin
gomez with us he is studying theology
and also in construction work and
painting
and he is also a minister of music today
he will be blessing us with the peace
the holy city
last night i let us sleep in
there came a dream so far
i stood in old jerusalem
beside the temple there
i heard the children singing and never
ask they sign me to all the boys
yes
is
[Music]
yes
and let me thought my dream was change
the stress no longer run
or show the glide of sun eyes
the little children sang
the songs will die with mystery
the moon
oh
is
[Laughter]
and once again the sin was changed
i saw the holy city
beside the telescope
the light of god was on the streets
last thing
my
is
with us
[Music]
amen
amen that was a beautiful rendition we
want to thank you kevin uh
for that beautiful piece that you have
given
us at this time and now we will continue
into the the program and i would love
for
every individual to be able to take this
time to
gather up your bible gather your notepad
gather your pen
or pencil for this is going to be an
extravagant moment
as the holy spirit is going to give us
an
understanding upon the word of god
and today we have joined with us an
international speaker
none other than elder randy skeet
he too is a husband and a humble man of
god
he is a graduate of oakwood university
and
also of the sda theological
seminary at andrews university where he
studied
for the ministry as he would say i would
ask
that you pray that god will put his
words
in his mouth listen be reverent and
think as he speaks please welcome
elder randy skeet
one moment we uh are having some
technical difficulties
uh pastor randy skee can you please put
your device off there you go
am i all right can you hear me now we
can hear you loud and clear
okay okay all right thank you very much
it's a pleasure for me and the privilege
really
to be a part of this program again i'm
grateful for it
and i hope that someone listening will
be touched will be enlightened
by what we have to say not what i have
to say alone but what we have to say
the bible says my people are destroyed
for lack of knowledge and it is
knowledge that we need so much
john 17 3 this is life eternal that they
might know thee the only true god
and jesus christ and by the same so i
thank god for this opportunity i'm now
in
actually in houston i just finished
preaching at the church about half an
hour ago
and now i'm here thank god i'm able to
do this
and so i'm ready by the grace of god to
do what i can to enlighten god's people
i enjoy the singing from the brother
who's studying god bless you
thank you very much for the powerful
voice that god has given you i say that
very sincerely
i love good singing so god bless your
voice
and my brother the host god bless you
and dr mccurchien as usual god bless you
very much
and god bless everyone who's listening i
suspect your presence means you have a
love for the truth
all right i'm ready
thank you so much elder skeet for tuning
in all the way from texas i'm here
tuning in from
guyana in south america oh really um
yes looking
my grandmother this funeral our first
question
is a series of questions versus what
is the nature of jesus is coming
you have secret how do we explain
matthew chapter 24 verses 40 and 41
where the bible reads speak holy ghost
then shall
we
then shall two be in the field but one
shall be taken
and the other left two women shall be
like the male difficulties
two women shall be grinding at the mill
and one shall be taken
and the others
[Music]
is it my turn
yes all right the first part of the
question if i recall
what is the manner of the second coming
of christ
before we get into what is the manner of
the second coming of christ
we need to discuss what is the necessity
for the second
coming of jesus christ it is absolutely
essential
you see god made a world and in verse 31
of genesis 1 he said
the bible says and god saw everything
that he had made what did he make
verse 1 in the beginning god created the
heaven and the earth
he saw all of that it was very good but
we know that sin
entered and ruined what god
created god now has to come back
to restore what was lost so he has to
come back
for that reason there is another reason
why god has to come back
he made a promise to abraham in genesis
12 13 he repeated it to isaac
and to jacob that they would inherit
canaan
that they would literally inherit the
earth when god told abraham he would
make him a great nation
and he would inherit what is called now
canaan or call then
god actually meant that he would inherit
the whole world and this is made very
clear in romans 4 13
the promise that abraham should be the
heir of
the world hebrews 11 verse 13 tells us
these all died in faith not
having received the promises but having
seen them afar
off and were persuaded of them and
embraced them
and confessed that there were strangers
and pilgrims on the earth
abraham lived according to hebrews 11 9
as
a stranger with isaac and jacob the
heirs with him
of the same promise how can abraham live
as a stranger
in a land promised to him because the
promise of the land was at two levels
physically and also spiritually in the
sense
that that promise extended to the new
world abraham died
not having received that promise so did
isaac
so did jacob so did many of the great
patriarchs
jesus christ must come back
to keep his word to abraham
i cannot say that more emphatically
jesus
christ made a promise to abraham
the bible says in numbers 23 verse 19
god is not a man that he should lie
neither the son of man that he shall
repent hath he said
and shall he not do it or have he spoken
and shall he not make it good
he has to make good on his promise that
the seed of abraham
would occupy that land and the land
pointed to the entire world
and we see that in genesis 13 verse 14 i
believe it is the bible say
and the lord said at the abram after
that lot was separated from him
lift up that eyes now and look from the
place with our
northward and southward and eastward and
westward that's the whole world
for all the land which thou seest to
thee will i give it until i see it god
was literally telling abraham
i will give you the entire world
including the area
that lot so selfishly took for himself
and so jesus christ
must come back to keep his promise to
abraham
and as i usually say this is a
tremendous a support for the reliability
of god's word
not even death can keep god from
fulfilling his word
the resurrection will be god taking an
ultimate step to keep his word he
reverses
death in order to keep his promise
he promised abraham and he must keep
that word and so the resurrection
the second coming of christ is
absolutely necessary
for the restoration of the way things
were to the way things were
and to keep his promise to abraham so he
has to come back
now the manner of his return is so
simply stated in the bible
i don't know why people say he's coming
quietly and rapturing the saints
in 1st thessalonians chapter 4 verse 16
we're familiar with that passage
for the lord himself shall descend from
heaven with a shout
with the voice of the archangel with the
trump of god
and the dead in christ shall rise first
notice what verse says
the lord himself shall descend from
heaven with
a shout with the voice of the archangel
with the trump of god these three
expressions simply mean it will be
a loud affair that will raise the very
dead because the shout and the trump
really refer to the voice of the savior
you know in john 11
43 when jesus raised lazarus the bible
says then he cried with a
loud voice lazarus come forth he will
cry with a
much louder voice when he raises the
righteous dead
and so the coming of christ will be
known by all who are alive
on the earth psalm 50 verse 3
our god shall come and shall not keep
silent a
fire shall devour before him and it
shall be very tempestuous round about
him
matthew 24 27 as the lightning shining
from the east to the west
that is how the coming of christ will be
and so his coming will be
visible it will be seen it will be felt
it will be heard now a part of the
question was how do you explain matthew
40. two shall be in the field one taken
one left
two grinding at the middle one taken one
left
let's go back to uh the days of noah
because this is just explaining
two classes not so much two individuals
two classes of people in the days of the
flood because prior to reading matthew
40 we have to read 36-37 and 38
meaning the coming of christ will be as
it was in the days of noah
and we read the same thing in luke 17 27
or 26 to 30.
so as we keep in mind the way it was in
the days of lot the way it was in the
days of noah
there were two classes one was taken the
other was left
noah was taken into the ark by god and
the unbelievers were left on the outside
lot was taken out of the city by god the
unbelievers were left
when christ comes the second time some
will be taken by him
others will be left the flood came and
took them all away
and so we're talking about two different
classes of people
elon white writes their only two classes
in the world today
and only two classes will be recognized
into judgment those who violate god's
law
and those who obey and so one taken one
left
those taken are taken with christ and
he's gone for a thousand years
those left are the ones who destroyed
that's what the taken and the left
really means all right i know i rushed
through that but i hope i said something
you got
no amen amen thank you for that elder
randy skeet
and if anyone wants to just get a
synopsis of what he said
uh just as abraham he was waiting for
that promise
uh to be fulfilled um one thing i would
love to take from that is from hebrews
uh we go back to hebrews 11 and they
noticed and recognized
that they were pilgrims and strangers
upon the earth and we
also have to understand that we're just
visiting we're not here to settle
and be here for a lifetime right even
though that's something that
a lot of evangelical christians may
believe you know so
that is important and there's not going
to be a secret rapture where
the plane uh you're in a plane and half
of the people in the plane are
immediately going to disappear
and then the plane is just oh where's
the pilot right it's going to be at
one moment where life will come through
those clouds so let us be ready
all right so the next question elder
randy sweet is
how do we know when jesus is coming
is it true that not even jesus knows
when he will come based upon matthew 24
36 which states but of that day and hour
knoweth no man no not the angels of
heaven
but my father only and is it true
that during the time of trouble the day
and the hour of christ's return will be
revealed
what is the evidence okay all right
multi-multi-faceted questions all right
let me try to remember
the first part of the question we'll
read it again the first part of the
question
how do we know when jesus is coming he
gave us signs
in matthew 24 luke 21
and in mark 13 he gave us signs because
that's what the disciples asked him
what shall be the sign of thy coming and
at the end of the world and so jesus
gives a lot of signs
of his coming of course the first thing
he said is let no man deceive you
so there are signs given in matthew 24
luke 21 and mark chapter 13.
thus we ought to study those chapters to
learn the signs of the return of jesus
christ and we can see them being
fulfilled in our present life
uh the second part of the question read
it again
second question is it true that not even
jesus knows when he will come
matthew 24 36 but of that hour knoweth
no man
not the angels in heaven but my father
now
there was a time when john and james
came to christ and said the mother came
to christ and said put my sons one of
the left one on the right
in your kingdom jesus said it's not mine
to give it's the father's power
and privilege to do that it is the same
thing with the coming of christ
it is not christ's privilege to make
that known it is the father's privilege
to declare that time
it is not that christ doesn't know it is
not christ's role to
make it known do you understand what i'm
trying to say it is not christ's
position to make
norm the time of the coming but christ
is god
and god knows everything now in his
humanity
and christ is speaking in his humanity
christ did not know because when he
raised lazarus from the dead
in john 11 34 he said where have you
laid him
and he said lord come and see he did not
know where
lazarus was laid why because in his
humanity
he did not know everything luke 2 52 and
jesus
increased in wisdom and stature and in
favor with god and man he had to learn
as god he knows everything but the
father the son and the holy spirit have
different responsibilities
it is the father's privilege to declare
when the coming actually will be it is
not the role of jesus to do that
it is the role of christ to be high
priest not the role of the father
it is the world of the holy spirit to
convict not the role of the other
members of the godhead
and so the father will decide when he
will let us know the coming of
of his son jesus christ but jesus as god
he knows when that time exactly is and
elohim does tell us in great controversy
i think it's chapter 40 or 41
where she says just before christ comes
the voice of god will be heard declaring
the exact date
and time of his coming yes so our
prophet tells us that will be announced
but only the believers will recognize
that voice
in john 12 there was a voice from heaven
said i have both glorified it and will
glorify it again
the people thereby the people that stood
by heard it said
it thundered others said an angel spake
to him only jesus
understood that voice so it would be
when the father announces the coming of
christ the exact day
only the believers will recognize his
voice and will be able to understand
he's telling them
that the coming is very very near but
jesus as god he knows but when he speak
in his humanity he did not know but he's
also telling us
it is the father's privilege to make
known the exact date and time
of the return of his son amen
did i miss any part of the question i
believe you answered the next question
and is it true that during the time of
trouble the day in the hour price return
will be revealed
okay okay great great let's move along
to the next question
it says matthew 24 15 and 16
tell us to flee the mountain when we see
the abomination
of desolation in the holy place how
will we know when the abomination of
desolation
has come okay good question
let's pray again father in heaven as we
continue with this very very vital
program give us the spirit of truth they
god
in jesus name i pray amen when studying
matthew 24 luke 21
mark 13 we have to keep in mind there
are two levels of interpretation
christ was detailing events that
actually happened in this time
but there also is an application of our
time when he talked in
matthew 24 15 when he therefore shall
see the abomination of desolation spoken
of by daniel the prophet
who so readeth let him understand let
them that be in judea flee
into the mountains that actually
happened between 1866 and 70.
the romans came surrounded the city 66
after a while they withdrew
mysteriously during that time of absence
the christians in the city left and
illinois says not one christian was
killed
when the armies came back of the romans
so the romans withdrew
by god's arrangement the christians left
and they fled to the mountains as jesus
had said the abomination of desolation
the abomination
is the roman army because if you read
the same passage in luke
luke 21 verse 20 said when he shall see
jerusalem
compass about with armies then know the
desolation is nigh
so luke says when you see armies
surrounding jerusalem
you know the desolation so desolation
and abomination are two separate things
but connected
the abomination the roman army because
they worship false gods
and the height of abomination is idol
worship and so the romans are
declassified as abomination
the desolation is the destruction of the
temple of jerusalem
now the holy place in matthew 24 verse
15 does not refer to the holy place
in the sanctuary that's not what it
refers to the place of the jews
considered holy place the holy ground
the holy land because when the armies
came
they did not come into the city at first
they came around the city
for quite a while before they finally
broke in and so the holy place there
does not refer particularly
to the holy place which is separate from
the most holy or the most holy place
it simply refers to the territory of
jerusalem which was considered by god's
people
as holy and the abomination did not
belong there you see
here are idol worshipping people right
in the territory of god's people
so the holy place does not refer to the
tabernacle the abomination
the roman armies and luke makes that
clear when you see armies surrounding
now
there is no jerusalem to be surrounded
by armies prophetically
in these last days but if the
abomination pointed to the roman armies
the abomination nowadays will be the
false
teachings that have come into the church
and
surrounded the church there is a lot of
false teaching in our church
our official doctrines are sound but
there are many members who believe
all sorts of strange things and by the
way god allows eric the church to shake
his church
to see where people are he doesn't have
to see what we have to see
and so there is no army that will
surround modern jerusalem
as a sign that crisis is coming the next
jerusalem will be the one that comes
down
and sits on the mount of olive and it
spits and becomes a great plane
and so the abomination of desolation you
must read matthew 24 15
16 luke 21 20 and 21 and mark 13
verse 14. it refers to the armies that
will
because mark says when you see the
abomination of desolation
stand in the place where it or not
that's what mark says it is standing
where he shouldn't be
this is jerusalem the holy place
abomination does not belong
false worship idol worship in the last
days
false worship idol worship worship of
the beast
that's our abomination that we have to
deal with but the abomination of
desolation the days of christ was
a reference to the roman armies that's
the abomination the destruction of the
temple and jerusalem
is the desolation also he
mentioned in daniel 9 and daniel
8. that's why jesus says spoken of by
daniel the prophet
amen amen and if you would all love to
be able to get a
detailed understanding of what happened
uh with the destruction of the temple
it's actually recorded in the great
controversy in the first few chapters
yes
and it's it's it's it's really shocking
to see exactly
what happened and it's amazing to see
how the christians
know christian as you mentioned uh was
killed but
millions of jews unfortunately lost
their lives because they did not want to
listen
to the prophecy of jesus christ and so
as we continue into the next question uh
we have to
say something let me say so go ahead the
jews rejected christ
okay they rejected christ but they they
presumably loved his law
in our age people reject the law but
they accept christ that can't work
they've rejected the law you know allah
will be passed making sunday the sabbath
officially
that is the same thing as uh rejecting
christ
because to reject truth is to reject its
offer you understand
and that the law is the truth to reject
god's sabbath commandment
is to reject the creator and so as
verily as ancient jerusalem was
destroyed for rejecting christ
so those in the last days will be
destroyed for rejecting
the law of christ which is a transcript
of his very character
and a person is no more than that
person's character
so back then they rejected jesus in the
last days they reject him by rejecting
his law
and the center of god's law is the
sabbath commandment
amen amen for that thank you for
clarifying upon that as well
um now there's one there was one part in
the question
i think you answered it fully but there
was is that the
man of sin it was part of a question in
there no
no no the man of sin is a reference to
the little horn of daniel 7 the man of
sin is in second thessalonians chapter 2
and of course the beast of revelation 13
that's the man of sin and that's the
people system the roman system
that is not of course they grew out of
the political roman system
produced the spiritual roman system so
there's a connection
but strictly speaking the man of sin
rose to prominence in 5 38 that's
hundreds of years
after jesus christ died and went back
what surrounded jerusalem
was the you can say the spiritual
ancestors of the man of sin
which is the roman army but remember we
have pagan rome and papal rome
so pagan rome surrounded jerusalem papal
rome
will seek to destroy spiritual jerusalem
and that's us
wow wow take those notes everyone
all right thank you for that elder and
now we're going to go into the next
question
and it says after jesus comes the second
time
will the world have another opportunity
to repent
and will there be a universal conversion
this is one of the most catastrophic
errors taught in christianity today
that when jesus christ comes back there
will be an opportunity to repent
it is wrong it is deadly that kind of
belief is suicidal
the bible is very clear in revelation 13
revelation 14 sorry
verse 14 and i looked and behold a white
cloud
and upon the cloud once sat like under
the sun of man having on his head a
golden crown
in his hand a sharp sickle the word
sickle is used 11 times in the bible
seven times in the new testament four
times in the old each time
it is connected to harvest another seven
times in the new testament
six are in revelation 14 which has to do
with the two harvests
the harvest of the right both are right
right for god
ripe against god now the son of man
on the cloud has on his head a golden
crown which means he is not
coming as a priest in leviticus 16 verse
part of the priest's garment was he
shall have a linen miter upon his head
it identifies him as the priest carrying
out the work of intercession
jesus comes back not as a priest
the priest didn't carry a sickle he
carried a scepter
with the the instance of christ merits
christ
comes as a king with a crown and a
sickle
to reap a harvest that has reached
maturity
he is not coming to give people a second
chance
the chance to get right with christ is
now not tomorrow
now because you may die tonight god
forbid and so there's no such thing
as an opportunity to repent when jesus
christ comes back that
opportunity is now and that now is in
capital letters italicized underlying
ball print
now he is not coming as a priest that is
over
in revelation 8 and he filled the center
and cast it in the earth
intercession is over probation closed
he that is unclean let him be unclean
either this filthy
let him be filthy still the records are
sealed that they close
all cases decide he's coming to take his
people home
and to prepare for the thousand years of
judgment
so anyone waiting to repent when jesus
comes you'll be surprised right into the
fires of hell
thank you for that explanation elder and
so the next question that we have after
that is
when does the millennium take place
where will god's people be
and where will the wicked be
in revelation 20 we have most of the
information about the millennium
the millennium will be in heaven will be
spent in heaven we're told in
first corinthians 6 1-3 we shall judge
the world
we shall judge angels first corinthians
6 1-3
we shall judge the world we shall judge
angels now we know from about in the
bible that there's a judgment going on
now called the investigative judgment
more commonly called by bible scholars
the pre-advent judgment
because god you see first corinthians 15
tells us that the dead shall be raised
incorruptible
in order to be raised from the dead
incorruptible an incorruptible person
does not need a judgment are you
following me
a judgment has already been carried out
to decide the fate of that person
you come from the grave incorruptible
immortal
there's no need to judge you the
judgment is going on now
when that judgment ends that's when
jesus christ comes back
then during the thousand years there
will be another judgment
not to decide who will be saved or lost
but to decide
the extent of the punishment for the
saints to work with christ to examine
the cases of those who will be lost
because we must be satisfied
that all his judgments are just going to
revelation 15.
god does not have to do that but he does
it when god
came down to destroy the world by a
flood or when he intended to
he discussed it with noah noah
represented the earth god does not
surprise us
before he destroys sodom and gomorrah he
discusses with abraham
are you following me those are the two
events jesus uses
to help us understand the coming of
christ a second time
before by the way before he destroys
this earth
the same way he spoke through noah and
he spoke through a lot
he is speaking through the seventh after
this church that's why we're seventh-day
adventists
he's trying to work through us to warn
the world
because god does not inflict judgment on
without first discussing it with a
representative of the earth
noah was the representative abraham was
locked was
we are in these last days although we're
ashamed to say
when christ comes he takes his people
home with him for a thousand years
we're judging the wicked and the fallen
angels
that's why the saints shall judge the
world and the saints shall judge
angels we know the punishment for sin is
death
but it's not death by firing squad it is
not death by lethal injection
it's death by fire then the question
arises how long will the fire burn how
long will a person burn
before he or she is burned up to ashes
that will be part of the judgment
the extent of the punishment before the
person is blotted out
the saints will be involved in that with
jesus christ because the bible says
behold i come quickly and my reward is
with me to give every man
according on the other side of that coin
by the way it's not part of the question
that i'll say
the righteous will have various levels
of privilege in heaven
and in the new world various levels
this is not unfair among the angels now
some are higher than others
gabriel is the highest before gabriel it
was lucifer
and so we are rewarded accordingly
some receive much some receive a little
the talents
some had five some had two but jesus
said well done to the two men who used
those faithfully and so the thousand
years was spent in heaven
on the earth desolation only satan and
the evil angels are alive
they have no one to tempt a thousand
years the devil will think about all
that he has done
by the way choose the first resurrection
to come up
not the second the bible says blessed is
he that hath
part in the first resurrection and such
the second death hath no power
revelation 20 verse 6 if you're blessed
coming up in the sec first resurrection
what are you coming up in the second
that's not the resurrection in which
to come up because it is resurrection to
destruction
the wicked will be raised at the end of
thousand years they will see the lives
they've lived they will all declare that
jesus christ is just
the bible says philippians 2 every
tongue shall confess
every initial bow what's the confession
jesus christ
is lord to the glory of god the father
the father's name
must be vindicated and even those who
are lost
will finally admit god has always been
just
and the last voice to make that
admission you know who that is
satan himself and he will be the last
one to be consumed eloise says
he burns for days and days
because he is the originator of sin and
the one who
tempted people to sin he by the way let
me also say this
it's not in the question but let me say
the wages of sin
is death okay now
all those who are lost will burn for
their own sins
are you following me all those who are
lost will burn
and pay for their own sins those who
were saved
those are the ones whose sins go on as a
zeal in leviticus 16
on the end of the day of atonement they
appeared on azazil
he's taken out to the wilderness by a
strong man representing jesus into the
wilderness he cannot come back into the
camp
sin will be no more that's the teaching
we must take
satan is as a zeal to scapegoat he will
suffer and burn for
not in a saving way but in a retributive
way
for the sins of all those who are saved
he will burn now
which means the more people he gets into
hell with him
the less he has to burn you're not
following me
the more people he gets into the fires
with him they'll burn for themselves you
understand
but the more people will save the more
he has to pay in the fires of hell
that's why he tries to get us to sin
because he's looking out for himself
not for you let me say it again the
devil does not look out for you
if he gives you things he's just
threatening you for the kill
the end of thousand years christ comes
back the wicked see their lives
they admit god is right then they're
consumed and the last person to burn
is the devil but for those thousand
years will be in heaven
the plan of salvation is not yet
finished it is only completed
when the devil is destroyed the world is
made brand new
then it is finished the day of atonement
was not finished
until azazeel was taken out into the
wilderness that god couldn't come back
representing the sin will never return
the second time then a new field was
placed in the most holy place
and that was the end of it and so the
plan of salvation its totality
is not yet finished it is finished
at the end of the thousand years
i hope someone learned something and and
definitely what i would say is if you
want to find
uh a detailed explanation upon that you
can go to leviticus 16
yes that gives us an understanding about
the scapegoat um and how it relates to
revelation 20. 16 from verse 20.
correct correct praise god for that and
uh
one of the things i would always say is
i mean you already answered it though i
mean the devil and his angels will be
there
for a thousand years and it's i mean
they have all that time you know
all that time and it just shows you how
much mercy god still has
um that he doesn't immediately destroy
them right he gives them time
to be able to understand that it was
actually them that caused
these problems right now we're going to
the next question elder
and this is going to be the final ques
actually two questions left and then
we'll actually open it up for forms and
questions upon social media and it says
many people have been
hearing that jesus is coming for
generations
yes yes but he has not yet come
how can we be sure that jesus is
returning and what does satan's last and
great deception
have to do with jesus coming all right
yes we've heard for many many years that
christ is coming but if you're a student
of the bible
a student of prophecy let me stress that
a student of prophecy
you've studied at 2300 day prophecy you
know that christ
could not have come before 1844 he could
not have come before then
now 1844 october 22 according to bible
prophecy
christ moved into the the most holy
ministry
most holy segment of his ministry which
began the pre-advent investigative
judgment
that has to take place before christ
comes back
so christ could not have come into this
appall in the days of martin luther in
the days of john wesley
according to prophecy now he could have
come back sometime
after 1844. yes that's why there's no
prophetic time
beyond october 22 1844. by the way if
you're listening to someone who's
telling you their dates in 18 uh
1989 or 2015 do not listen to that
with the bible gives no prophetic dates
that extend beyond october 22
1844 and white is clear she said she was
shown
that prophetic time does not extend
beyond october 22
1844 but many times people want to
introduce something new
and sensational and they come up with
dates do not
listen to someone trying to tell you
there's some specific prophetic date
that extends beyond october 22 1844
after that christ could have come like
tells us they were twice christ wanted
to come
a few years after 1844 and shortly after
1888 at a minneapolis conference
a general conference he wanted to come
but the brethren did not receive the
light the way they should and their life
was wrong but christ could have come
anytime between 1844 and now
but it is also true that while we have
heard this for a long time
it simply means we are much closer than
those who heard it before us we are much
closer and keep in mind
that the coming of christ in a certain
sense is your death
what do i mean by that when you die
that's it
what if you die tonight what difference
does it make if he comes next to the
other week after
you're dying tonight get yourself ready
with christ tonight
so don't get worked up well my
grandmother said he's coming he hasn't
come
you don't have a guarantee on a long
life you may be dead tonight
get ready for him tonight well not
tonight get ready for him today
you may not see tonight and stop you
know agonizing over when he hasn't come
in his mercy he's given you some time to
stop what you're doing and to get right
with him in his mercy
then take that opportunity but christ
will come why does he have to come
because he said i'm coming john 14 1-3
let me pray again father
as we continue speak words of truth i
pray please in jesus name
amen john 14 1-3 let not your heart be
troubled you believe in god
believe also in me in my father's house
are many mansions
if it were not so i would have told you
i go to prepare
a place for you and if i go and prepare
a place for you i will come again
and receive you unto myself we're not
yet with jesus
he's represented by the spirit but we
are not yet with jesus he said
receive you unto myself that where i am
there you may be also we are not where
jesus
is literally we're there he represents
us but we are not there
the ambassador united states to japan
represents united states
but i'm not in japan but he represents
my country are you following me
jesus represents us but we are not in
heaven
he said i've got to come back and take
you so you and i can be together
in a specific place now the bible says
in titus 1 2
god cannot lie numbers 23 19 god cannot
lie
then he must come back because he said
he's coming back
and you can trust the word of someone
who said let there be light and there
was light
that word has not lost its power christ
said i'm coming back and he's coming
back by the way that doctrine is so
important
he not preached the second coming of
christ you read the book of jude verses
14 15
enoch preached the second coming of
christ enoch was alive when adam was
alive they lived together for many years
my reader or listeners may be surprised
enoch and adam
lived together many years that tells you
how early the second coming was preached
but it goes further back than that
in genesis 3 15 and i will put enmity
between thee and the woman between thy
seed and her seed
it shall bruise thy head and thou shalt
bruise his heel
now keep this in mind and listen to
romans 16 20 and now the god of peace
shall brew satan under your heels
shortly wait a minute this is straight
out of genesis 3 15. listen to paul
the god of peace shall brew satan under
your feet shortly
this is a future event meaning the
bruising of his head
spoken of in genesis 3 15 includes
calvary
but it also includes what will happen at
the end of the thousand years
when the when his head is permanently
bruised
he is still active and so he's not
destroyed
you're following me and so when god said
i will put him with me
and he shall bruise thy head that goes
all the way past the second coming
to the third coming at the end of
thousand years and so the coming of
christ was preached in genesis 3 15
which includes the gospel he not
preached it and he lived in theirs of
adam
that doctrine has to be significant to
have such an
early beginning in the history of this
world
christ is coming back and he may come
today for you because you may close your
eyes in death
the question is why has they come the
question is am i ready if he pops up
right now
sorry my brother for my long responses
next question
praise god praise god and it's important
as
christians that we have patience we are
willing to endure
yes yes until the end no matter how long
it may take for christ to come because
uh one moment we give up
that might be just the moment christ
comes
thank you for that elder so the next
question is what practical preparation
should we make
for jesus's return james chapter 2 verse
12. now james is the half brother of
jesus
here's what jim says let's read from
verse 8
if he observed the royal law according
to the scripture
thou shalt love thy neighbor as thyself
ye d well you do well
but if you have respect to persons you
commit sin and are convinced of the law
as transgressors
for whosoever shall keep the whole law
and yet offending one point he's guilty
of all
verse 11 for he that said do not commit
adultery he said also do not kill
now if thou commit nor adultery but if
you kill you
become a transgress of the law now verse
12 says so speaky
and so do as they shall be judged by the
law of liberty
james says live your life as if you
understand that one day you will have to
you will be judged in accordance with
the standard of righteousness
the ten commandments of god the question
how should i live live
a life of obedience to god your
obedience does not save you jesus saves
you
but if he saves you from sin he saves
you from disobedience and so what's the
practical preparation
do live a life of obedience to god
by the power of jesus christ he set the
example
and he's he's waiting and willing and
wanting
to express that example in your life as
you surrender constantly
the practical preparation live a life of
submission to god
and obedience to god
amen amen all right let's go to the
next question and so we have two forum
questions first
up and the first question is from david
hutchinson and he asked
elder will the anti-deluvian and the
inhabitants of sodom and gomorrah
witness the coming of christ
or will they have to wait until the
second
resurrection the second resurrection
sacrifice
now there will be a special resurrection
eloise talks about that but the bible
also hints at it
revelation 1 7 behold he cometh with
clouds and every eye shall see him
and they also which pierced him those at
christ trial like herod and pilate
there will they will be raised to see
him come literally
then struck down again by his brightness
there will be a special resurrection
also
for those who died under the third
angels message by the way let me slow
down
those who crucified christ will be
deliberately raised to see
him come back when he said you know when
they
put a crown on his head you're the king
of the jews and they beat him up they
made fun of the king of the universe
they will see him coming in the clouds
of glory
then they'll be struck down but those
from sodom and and before the flood nara
they won't be raised up no they'll come
up for their destruction
at the end of the thousand years but
like i said earlier come up in the first
resurrection not the second
please you you got to make sure that
story right all right great
thank you for that and the next question
is from prish raj
ranjev and he asks what is the
difference between the faith of jesus
and
having faith in jesus the faith of jesus
is the belief that christ is able to
save you completely
fully entirely from any spiritual melody
that you may be suffering
the faith that we are to have the
commandments of god the faith of jesus
it is not jesus's faith and his father
saves us it is
accepting christ fully as a savior who
is
fully able to save us until we accept
that with all our heart and soul and
mind and strength
we accept that this god this savior
can deliver me from drugs from alcohol
cigarettes gambling
whatever my sickness is spiritually
god can deliver me from the utmost
condition
that is the faith of jesus
amen amen there is no possibility when
it comes to saving someone there is no
one
whose situation is so bad the person
can't be saved the faith of jesus
his ability to save us completely
although some people believe you have to
say no you don't have to
you got a savior who can save you
completely
all right next question praise god the
next question
that we have is i believe coming from
brother samuel and he asked the question
is
it it is almost as israel refute
israel's refusal to possess the promised
land
uh what should have taken 40 days took
40 years
could it be the same for us today as god
brought more trials to test their faith
could it be the same for us yes it is
the same for us
we should have been in heaven long
before this as was the case with the
israelites
so it was a form of a curse that god put
on them and he sent them back into the
wilderness why
because they disobeyed him so yes we are
that's what 100 and you can do the math
170 something or 80 something years ago
christ could have come a long time he
has not come because of power and
faithfulness so yes
there's a parallel between ancient
israel and modern israel when i say
modern israel
i do not mean that nation in the middle
east i mean god's people to whom he has
committed
his ten commandments as verily as he
committed the commandments to ancient
israel
yes we are following the same path as
ancient israel
thank you for that elder and if anyone
has a question please
upload it upon the comment section okay
we have another question but please
upload your questions
uh we have about seven minutes to be
able to answer a few more questions from
elder skeet
and this question is coming from chelsea
and she says
can we be sure we are going to make it
into heaven
while on earth or is that just
being presumptuous if your life is in
the hands of jesus
if your life is given completely to
christ
you needn't have no worry about your
eternal salvation
give your life to christ he will save
you
paul said i'm persuaded that he's able
to keep that which i have committed unto
him
against that day i am persuaded he's
able to keep me second timothy chapter 2
verse 12 chapter 1 verse 12. he will
keep you so don't have any doubts give
your life to christ
completely and you have nothing to worry
about so you don't run around saying i'm
safe you run around saying you don't run
around saying anything but if you ask
you simply say
i have given my life to christ it's up
to him to decide what he'll do with it
but i've given it to him and i renew
that surrender every day
and the surrender must be complete
faithful works page 100 paragraph 1
god requires the entire surrender of the
heart in order for justification to take
place and in order for men to retain
justification
there must be continual obedience
through active living faith
that works by love and purifies the soul
daily
i surrender to god
and he will save me into his kingdom
so i'm not worried it is god who worries
not us
we make god worry because we're in and
out we're in and out in and out like the
israelites you read the book of judges
adultery you know idolatry god punishes
them idolatry they're in and out god is
always biting his nails over his people
that's what we make god worry we don't
have to worry when the life is given to
christ
we're giving the life to someone who is
not willing that we should perish
why are you worrying but that giving of
the life must be 100
amen amen thank you for that and uh the
next question that we have
is can you share more light upon the
investigative judgment
and the parable of the wedding
investigative judgment is
is an activity going on right now
in matthew 22 there's a from verse 11
the king
has a feast for his son
before the sun comes in the king comes
in to examine the guests
he finds one without a wedding garment
throws him out now that refers to the
investigative judgment the examination
of the guests the guest being
those who at some point have professed a
relationship with jesus christ
before his son comes in before the sun
comes to this earth
there must be an investigation and that
goes all the way back to eden god came
down to investigate what happened
when cain killed abel god came down to
investigate when he was about to send
the flood he came down to investigate
god came down in the person of christ to
investigate the condition of sodom and
gomorrah
god investigates not because he needs to
know we need to know
before he pulls out his judgment it has
been going on since october 14
october 2044 october 22 1844 based on
the prophecy of daniel 9
and it will end we don't know when it
will end we don't know when it ends it
begins at the house of the living first
first peter 4 17 it begins with the
house of god
first then it moves to the wicked it is
an examination but we need not worry
because a life given to christ in rome
uh
revelation three verse five he that
overcometh
the same shall be clothed in white
raymond romans three verse five and i
will not not have his name out of the
book of life but i will confess his name
before my father
and before his angels in this judgment
christ represents you
on whomever christ speaks for the father
accepts
so you need not worry is my name coming
up at two o'clock today
who has your life did you surrender that
lifestyle yes
you have nothing to worry about god is
defending his christ
is representing his people
but to be christ's people you must be
his entirely
if that's not the case you're just a
church member to be a child of christ
you must be his entirely
and so this judgment is going on and
most of the world does not know
and there's only one church on the face
of the earth commissioned to preach this
message as us
and we seldom do
by the way when christ came the first
time nobody knew virtually nobody knew
there was a nation commissioned to make
it known the jews they didn't
and so some shepherds were told after he
was born the wise men alone studied the
doctrine and they came to study the
scrolls
and they came when christ was already in
a house he was a
young child at the time but when he was
in the manger
the shepherds were sent by the angels
and nobody knew
there's judgment going on the world
needs to know
but don't be afraid of the judgment give
your life
to christ luke 18 two men went to the
temple to pray
a pharisee republican we know the
pharisee's prayer republicans lord be
merciful to me a sinner that's all he
said
christ said in verse 14 of luke knight
luke 18 he went down to his house
justified
daily daily we surrender to god ask for
mercy
and we are covered in that pre-advert
judgment it is a judgment
where the decision is made in our favor
because that was that's what christ is
doing
amen amen and one of the questions i
studied the chapter and great
controversy
investigative judgment mm-hmm sorry and
one of the questions i had elder skeet
in regard with
what we were supposed to be sharing with
the individuals the three angels message
uh the last message it talks about
babylon has fallen babylon has fallen
and it tells us about god's wrath yes
yes if you can just give a little
understanding about what that wrath will
be
okay well let's deal with the babylon
first babylon is a system of false
worship
and the heart of that system is the the
papal system
but babylon includes all false worship
not just uh so when babylon is falling
it's not the purple system is fallen
and apostate protestantism is not fallen
babylon encompasses
all false teaching but the central
figure of
babylon is of of that fallen system
is the roman system now what was
what the wrath of god god's greatest
expression of wrath will be the seven
last place
revelation 14 uh verse 9 11
it will be poured out on those who
accept the mark of the beast
the beast being the rome is the
roman the roman system god's
fiercest wrath will be poured out when
the bible says without mixture
means no mercy upon those who accept the
mark of the beast
and have his name the name mean you are
one with him
the mark being here's a behavior that
expresses your submission
that behavior is sunday observance
but let me say no one has that mark now
because it is not yet a law
when it becomes a law as it was a law in
the days of daniel and the three hebrew
boys or the three hebrew boys
to bow to the image it was a law because
daniel 3 4 says an
inheral cried aloud to you it is
commanded or people nations and
languages
it was a law break the second
commandment and worship an image
in these last days there will be a law
break the fourth commandment
and keep sunday when that happens and
people
choose that man-made law that's when
they have to mark the beast that's when
the fall of babylon
is complete when it finally makes its
law
the law of the land as a legal system
right now the fall is not complete it's
it's it's almost complete but it's not
complete
when that sunday law is made official
the fall would have been complete people
now have to decide where do i go
do i follow god do i follow a man-made
system by the way if you're listening to
me
sunday is not the sabbath i hate to be
so blunt but i do have a love sunday is
not the sabbath
it has never been it isn't now it will
never be
sunday worship came through uh
decrees by the apostate church and what
i mean is apostate church i mean those
who drifted from truth
and went into error because constantine
arranged for error to be mixed with some
truth
and the result is all bad the church
issued decrees constantine gave his law
in 3 21
that people should rest on sunday work
on saturday sunday
is not the sabbath no matter how
sincerely you keep sunday you're not
giving the sabbath god requires modern
sincerity he requires
truth first corinthians 5 18 let us keep
the feast
in sincerity and in truth joshua 25 i
believe is verse 14
we must serve god in sincerity and truth
john 4 24 god is a spirit and they that
worship god
must worship him in spirit and in truth
keeping sunday
is not worshipping god
it is simply honoring a man made system
and the bible says
thou shalt have no other gods before me
and so the wrath of god is poured out on
those
who have accepted a different law giver
james chapter 4 verse 12 says there is
one
lawgiver one who is able to save
and to destroy that is god most of the
christian world think there are two law
givers
there's god there's someone else who put
up sunday the bible says there is
one lawgiver that's jesus christ and he
tells us keep his father's commandments
and god's commandments do not include
sunday's the sabbath
amen and one thing i would love to add
is that it tells us in spirit of
prophecy that when the flood took place
uh the devil and the angels they were
afraid
for their life because of god's power
so imagine when the plagues come right
um but we should not
want to immediately want to follow jesus
because we're afraid of what things
constructed
because we love him with our whole heart
and so let us make that decision
that we will surrender our will and take
upon god's will in our life all right so
because of time we're actually
unfortunately going to have to
cease uh there unless uh elder skeeter
you you can
open up for a few more questions but
another question i'll take one or two
more
okay so we have two questions here let's
just do this
can you explain a little more the
parable of the ten virgins
i've always wondered why the five
virgins refused to share the extra
that they had at the darkest hour all
right
let's let me pray again fathers we
continue with these two questions
give us light i pray give us light in
jesus name i pray
amen you cannot transfer character are
you with me
your father's character cannot save you
mind
character and personality volume 2 page
4 23 paragraph 2
the gospel deals with individuals each
person has the soul to save or to lose
each has an indev individuality separate
and distinct from all others
each must be convicted for himself
converted for himself
he must choose to obey himself he must
exercise his conscience for himself
the five wise virgins had allowed the
oil to work in their lives
the five foolish did not do that so when
the crisis came
the coming of the bridegroom they said
give us some oil but you cannot give
oil to somebody else you must have oil
for yourself
and so but you'll observe if there were
10 virgins
there are a lot of nice people in the
church they're just nice behaviorally
but they have not allowed those the oil
the word of god to work in their lives
and when that crisis hits it'll be too
late
no other oil is available i cannot give
you some of my oil
because oil is available for everyone
and so the five wives represent those
who have allowed the spirit of god the
word of god
to work in their lives the five foolish
of those who were
called i have need of nothing you know
i'm increasing goods
i have need of nothing i don't break the
law of the land i don't kill i don't
steal i don't you know go and kill
people
but the word of god has not worked in my
life
and has not prepared me for the sudden
coming
of the bridegroom and so again there are
ten virgins
which means a lot of nice people are
going to hell are you following me a lot
of
nice people are going to hell they were
virgins they weren't violent
but the word of god did not work in
their lives
as a principle of daily life and so they
were lost the door was closed they
couldn't get in
and once the door is closed it's not
reopened which is another proof to us
when christ comes there's no chance you
can knock as much as you like it won't
open
when god shut the door of the ark i'm
sure those outside were knocking
it was not open because god shut the
door noah couldn't open it
amen and one thing i would love to share
is that even though it it records that
there was 10 virgins
and half were foolish it's
not to take literally that there's going
to be
50 of people going to have an investor
because only eight people out of
millions made it
into the art okay and so we have to
examine ourselves examine ourselves
thank you for that elder and uh one last
question
it is right here uh and this is from
earlier is uh when you were referring to
as we get closer and closer to the last
moments that god
may reveal the exact timing of his
return uh can you give us a little
understanding
on how we can search that and find that
for ourselves or all right i'll send it
to dr mccarthy and sheila and she can
make that
public i don't have it with me now i
know it says that yes
i'll get the precise quotation i'll send
it to her thank you thank you so we will
have that updated and
released for everyone to see for
themselves but
either way thank you so much elder randy
skeet for giving us an eloquent message
uh to be able to inform us of the second
coming of christ
jesus our lord may we all be ready for
that joyous day and may we be there
on what type of resurrection
the first resurrection the first
let me also say this let me say this
quickly two bible verses
second timothy chapter four verse eight
henceforth there's laid up for me
a crown of righteousness which the lord
the righteous judge shall give me at
that day
and not to me only but unto all those
also all them unto them also that love
his appearing
we must love the coming of christ in
hebrews 9 26
and to those that look for him shall he
re appear the second time without sin
and salvation
we must love the fact that christ is
coming we must
look for it in hebrews 11 verse 10
abraham
looked for a city which have foundation
there must be something about us
that express this expectation of the
coming of christ
it must absorb us christ is coming and
he must guide the way we live
amen when we all get to heaven yes
we all get to heaven it's going to be a
special experience for us all
don't miss it don't miss it please do
not miss it do not miss it
thank you for all of that information
which was definitely inspired to you by
the holy spirit
as you spoke through and and i encourage
every single individual do not just take
this information
record it and stash it away study for
yourself to show yourself approved
all right and so we will go now to the
remainder of the program
where we will be blessed once again by
an amazing singer and of course if any
of you have heard from sister alana sing
many times on the word inspired not only
is she willing to use her talents
for the lord but she is a professional
baker
and the founder and manager of kate by
alana
she also studies political science at
the university of rhode island
so she juggles the home life business
life
and studies although just 19
years old and so without further ado
please welcome
sister alana kwashi
hi thank you so much brother archie for
the introduction
and again thank you other skeet for
answering our questions
i hope you guys enjoy this song it is
called no more night
[Music]
heaven will pass
away it's not a dream
god will make all things new
that day gone is the curse
from which i stumbled and fell
banished to eternal
hell
no more nights
no more pain
no more tears
never crying again
and praises
to the great i
am we will live
in the lights of the
[Music]
reason
let's
[Music]
see all around
now the nations bow down
to sing the only sound
is the praises to christ
our kingdom
the names from the
book i read
i know the king
so there's no need
no need to direct
no more nights
no
never crying again
to the great
i am we will live
in the light
[Applause]
see over there there's a mansion
that's prepared just for me
where i will live with my savior
eternally
and there will be no more
[Music]
nights
no more pain
no
the great i
am we will live
in the light of the risen
unless oh wow jesus
i am we will live
in the light of the wind
[Music]
thank you
amen thank you for that sister kwashi
and now we will come down to the
conclusion
and on behalf of the sister denisha
mccurchion which unfortunately was not
able to
really give the ability to speak due to
technical difficulties
we want to thank god for his working
today can we get an amen in the comments
section for that
and i express sincere thanks to elder
randy skeet for answering the questions
through the quickening of the holy
spirit
we are so thankful that although you
are hosting a revival in texas you took
the time
out to participate so willingly in this
program
and thank you born again sdh church in
houston texas for setting up elder skeet
thank you brother kevin gomez for
serenading us with the holy city
thank you brother jonathan archie for
assisting me and asking the questions
and hosting the program am i talking to
myself
but this is denisha i appreciate you
taking this role
sister alana kwashi thank you for
ministering no more night
and thanks sister sasha shay weeks for
the prayer in advance
and thank you cousin errol henry for
ensuring reverence was preserved
throughout this encounter and that we
had
smooth transitions by spotlighting
persons and so forth
additionally thank you sister stacy ann
for moderating the
chat and i also extend thanks to my mom
for her prayers support and counsel
and thank you to all of you for joining
this session sharing commenting asking
questions subscribing
and following and before we conclude
into prayer i
want to give all of you an invitation
to one of the programs that will be
taking place led
once again by sister denisha mchurchen
and elder
randy skeet along by the side of chelsea
jack
and crystal gilbert and this will be
an extravagant event that will be taking
place on sabbath
june 5 at 2 p.m as we have a question
and answer session so have your
questions ready
uh there will be there will answer they
will answer questions there
uh in regard to what the millennium will
be
all about where will god's people be
where will the wicked be where will the
devil be
will he literally be cast into a bit
into a pit
so save the date and feel free to tune
in
and without further ado you can take it
away sister sasha
squeaks as we close in prayer
all right let us pray dear heavenly
father we thank you so much for this
wonderful program that we had this
evening we thank you
for your just timely reminders that the
time is now if we have not truly given
ourselves
to you the time is right now for us to
fill you know be fill um full of the
holy spirit for him to work
what he needs to work within each and
every one of us we pray lord that even
as we continue to go through the
remainder of
this day and just you know the remainder
of however long we might have
life here on this earth that we will
truly be your representatives that we
are able to study to show ourselves
approved
and more importantly lord that we really
live
your character so those that are in this
world could see
and come to know who you are personally
so when you return on that great
fateful day we are all able to join you
and be a part of your kingdom be
be with us even now and just continue to
bless us keep us all
whatever we may end up doing even at
this moment from here
just continue to watch over us and
protect us all we thank you and we love
you we praise you in jesus name
amen amen
peace be unto you all have a great
remainder of the sabbath with jesus
christ our lord
take care